von den über sieben milliarden menschen
auf dieser welt haben gerade einmal 27
milliarden einen verlässlichen
internetzugang
zwei drittel der menschen auf dieser
erde sind offline obwohl das internet
vielen leuten helfen könnte drei
projekte wollen nun den himmel erobern
um wirklich jeden menschen zu vernetzen
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge rotz und was für uns komplett
normal ist zum beispiel youtube videos
zu gucken oder mit anderen leuten bei
facebook zu schreiben die auf der
anderen seite der erde sind diese
möglichkeit haben viele menschen nicht
sie haben keinen internetzugang und das
kann an vielen möglichen sachen liegen
zum beispiel daran dass es zu teuer ist
internet leitungen zu verlegen
da könnte es sein zum beispiel dass die
bevölkerungsdichte einfach viel zu
gering ist das vielleicht nur alle paar
kilometer ein haus ist und das ist viel
zu teuer wäre gerade diese paar häuser
miteinander zu verbinden
es kann aber auch daran liegen dass das
gebiet in denen diese menschen wohnen
viel zu schwierig ist daran zu arbeiten
oder ganz schlicht und einfach dass das
land nicht genug geld hat trotzdem ist
das internet einfach wichtig und ich
denke mal da können wir uns alle darauf
einigen einfach super mehrere studien
haben sich in den letzten jahren mit dem
thema internet beschäftigt und dabei
herausgefunden wie wichtig einen zugang
zum internet sein kann
für viele kinder zum beispiel auf dieser
erde ist bildung immer noch keine
selbstverständlichkeit
das web bietet allerdings jetzt schon
riesige datenbanken wie zum beispiel
youtube wikipedia oder die carnica demi
mit denen sich diese kinder weiter
bilden könnten
was oft nur fehlt es ein günstiger
laptop oder eben internet bei den vielen
gesundheitlichen problemen in den
ländern der dritten welt kommt oft auf
10.000 einwohner nur ein einziger arzt
mit einem internetzugang könnten sich
die menschen allerdings informieren oder
sogar fern diagnostiziert werden bevor
sie sich auf den langen weg in ein
krankenhaus machen bauern könnten
bessere techniken zum anbau lernen und
wetterdaten nutzen um die ernte zu
steigern
laut der world bank zu sorgen der
internetzugang in einem land für eine
steigerung des bruttoinlandsprodukts um
immerhin 14 prozent und kleinere
betriebe wachsen doppelt so schnell mit
internet wie ohne internet und außerdem
steigert sich dabei die produktivität um
über zehn prozent
das internet einfach nur eine geniale
sache aber wie können wir über vier
milliarden menschen auf dieser welt
einen günstigen und vor allem
flächendeckenden internetzugang geben
hier sind drei projekte die sich genau
das zur aufgabe gemacht haben project
project jungs ein bereits relativ
fortgeschrittenes projekt von google
und es geht dabei um riesige ballons die
in der stratosphäre also circa 20
kilometer über der erde schweben
diese sogenannten luhns sollen einfach
umherfliegen und bilden dabei ein
riesiges netzwerk in der luft steuern
kann googles diese luftballons per höhen
regulierung
das heißt quasi wie ein fisch der seine
schwimmblase vergrößert und verkleinert
um auf- oder abzusinken können auch die
luhns einen kleineren ballon innerhalb
dieses größeren balance aufpumpen mit
präzisen wetterdiensten sollen die
ballons dann aufwind strömen surfen
können und so flächendeckenden
internetzugang bieten
die idee dahinter ist dass soweit ein
ballon zu weit weg trifft wird um zum
beispiel die verbindung zu verlieren das
dann schon der nächste in reichweite
kommt und die verbindung bereits
aufgenommen hat jeder einzelne dieser
balance soll auf einer fläche von bis zu
40 kilometern durchmesser internet
bieten
das ganze ist natürlich solar betrieben
und google arbeitet im moment noch daran
die lebensdauer dieser balance zu
verbessern
in der stratosphäre gibt es zum beispiel
sehr wenig druck von außen
deshalb lässt google die balance schon
vor dem start zur hälfte oder so aber
auch pumpen damit die nicht sofort
platzen der bislang beste balance über
sechs monate und umkreist die erde
neunmal bis er dann schließlich
irgendwann zerplatzt der projektmanager
möchte dass die balance mehrere jahre in
der luft bleiben können und dann sicher
landen um recycle zu werden
titan aerospace dieses jahr abbaut
superleichte solarbetriebene flugzeuge
die ohne piloten fliegen können die
können gerade genug gewicht packen um
die antennen für die internetzugänge
transportieren zu können
und lange zeit sah es so aus als würde
sich facebook diese staat unter den
nagel reißen denn ich denke mal neben
googles facebook will das unternehmen
das am meisten davon profitieren würde
wenn auf einmal vier milliarden menschen
mehr ins internet kommen
kleiner nebeneffekt facebook wird
inzwischen so sehr als eigenständiges
netzwerk angesehen dass in manchen
gebieten auf dieser erde einer von 20
leuten behauptet aktiv bei facebook zu
sein aber gleichzeitig gar kein internet
zu haben weil es auch egal
auf jeden fall hat sich dann im april
2014 google genau dieses unternehmen
geschnappt die drohnen wären perfekt um
die lücken zu schließen die vielleicht
von den ungenauen balance aufgerissen
werden könnten
die solar truhen sollen bis zu fünf
jahre lang am stück in der luft bleiben
können
und ansonsten sollen die genau so
funktionieren wie das netzwerk von
project lumi facebook hat dann
bekanntgegeben eigenständig solar
flugzeuge entwickeln zu wollen ohne sich
ein startup zu kaufen
seitdem hat man davon allerdings nicht
mehr so viel gehört und google behauptet
jetzt schon in diesem sommer die ersten
testflüge mit dem sogenannten drohnen
machen zu können
google wird meiner meinung nach immer
mächtiger und vielleicht kontrolliert
google bald die internet zugänge von
zwei dritteln der menschheit aber nicht
so schnell nicht so schnell
schließlich gibt es ja immer noch space
ex die firma von elon musk will das
satelliten-internet dass jeder ziemlich
hast revolutionieren
statt geostationäre satelliten 35
kilometer über der erde schweben zu
lassen will spacex über 4000 sehr kleine
sehr einfache satelliten in einer sehr
geringen höhe über der erde schweben
lassen
diese sollen dann zusammen auch ein
netzwerk bilden und das internet auf dem
boden streamen
im vergleich zu den ballons und den
drohnen die in ungefähr 20 kilometern
höhe sind sind die satelliten mit 800
bis 1000 kilometern entfernung immer
noch ewig weit entfernt die ersten
satelliten könnten bei diesem
ambitionierten projekt allerdings auch
erst in fünf jahren in den orbit gelangt
und erst in zwölf bis fünfzehn jahren
soll das ganze netzwerk an den start
gehen aber spacex wäre ja nichts basics
wenn sie nicht auch an die weit
entfernte zukunft denken würden und
deshalb wird auch direkt bekannt gegeben
dass man darüber nachdenkt ein ähnliches
netzwerk auf dem mars aufzubauen und
dann das system der erde mit dem system
vom mars miteinander zu verbinden also
quasi wlan im ganzen sonnensystem oder
internet ist einfach eine hammer sache
und der versuch möglichst vielen
menschen möglichst viel internet zu
geben ist meiner meinung nach einfach
super und genau das
kommen diese erfindung von mir einen
daumen nach oben aber was ist eure
meinung zu dem projekt meint ihr dass
das ganze funktionieren wird welches
projekt funktioniert am ersten schreibt
mir einfach unten in die kommentare
und ansonsten wenn euch das thema mars
interessiert habe ich noch eine sehr
gute buchempfehlung für euch nämlich der
marsianer das unglaublich witzig ist
aber auch spannendes buch über einen
astronauten der alleine auf dem mars
zurückgelassen wurde und ums überleben
kämpft er hat das ganze direkt zweimal
gehört weil es einfach witzig und lustig
fand und sehr spannend wenn ihr das
ganze kostenlos haben wollt dann klickt
einfach hier oben auf das buch oder
unten den ersten blick in der video
beschreibung und ansonsten vielen dank
fürs zuschauen wenn ihr bis sie geguckt
hat und bis zum nächsten donnerstag um
19 uhr